shortly after Dawn on Friday and yet
another Countrywide Russian missile
attack
the target as before Ukraine's energy
grid officials say nine power facilities
were damaged
the aim to freeze people into submission
air raid sirens in the capital Kiev
drove civilians underground seeking
shelter in the city's Metro stations
air defenses are said to have
intercepted most of the incoming
missiles but even then debris Must Fall
somewhere and it can fall anywhere
[Music]
and what else to do on a freezing Friday
on the ground but dance and sing
[Music]
oh
attacking our energy infrastructure
making people suffer during the winter
time that's about genocide of our nation
but I must admit that our moral is
extremely strong and we will never
surrender on Thursday far away in Geneva
the un's High Commissioner for human
rights warned that ongoing attacks on
energy infrastructure were exposing
Millions to extreme hardship
over 10 million consumers
are facing Cuts in electricity
and millions are cut off from a regular
supply of water and Heat
additional strikes could lead to a
further serious deterioration in the
humanitarian situation and Spark more
displacement
this was the scene at a residential
building in the Central City of krivirig
struck by a missile shot down or gone
astray and this a metro station another
impromptu shelter in the northern city
of kharkiv
we heard the explosions there were a lot
of them she says I was in a bus and the
electricity was still on but then the
power went out and we came down here now
we're waiting for the air raid alarm to
end
after the ninth such wave of attacks
since October with public food and
heating stations now in widespread use
ukrainians were left facing emergency
blackouts and plummeting temperatures as
this punishing wartime winter grinds on
Jonah Al Jazeera